ladies and gentlemen there's a lot of
really scary things going on in the
world today so I thought we should get
our mind off things
by watching top 10 scariest CGI effects
in movies from watchmojo.com dealing
with real terror let's look at fake
terror
are you excited John I am so excited to
be alarmed in a different way
[Music]
sugarplum fairies Dementors and
Cloverfield monsters hey guys i'm
rebecca from watch mojo and today we'll
be counting down our picks for the top
10 scariest CGI effects and movies
before we begin we publish new content
every day so we're sure to subscribe to
our channel and ring the bell to get
notified about our latest video do that
here too we'll be taking a matte
computer-generated monsters and visual
moments that chilled us to the boom all
right please note that we will be
including things that both CGI and
practical effects also since many of
these monsters show up at the end of
their respective movies a spoiler alert
is known as shock trap I wish I watched
movies no number 10 the Sugar Plum Fairy
[Music]
never forgot her as the survivors
proceeded into an elevator they're
treated to the sight of hundreds of
hunting monsters but this one stood out
from the rest after dealing with killers
so as the burroughs ballerina in an
elevator across from them as she turns
around however it's shown that she has
rows of teeth instead of a face
memorable monsters in the whole film for
takus this movie thing a lot number 9
dark seekers I am Legend
[Music]
I've ever watched this in the theaters
that was pretty scary like the whole
seat when he sees the crouches Will
Smith's Robert Neville is understandably
on edge as he journeys through the
post-apocalyptic streets of New York
City
considering the devastating effect the
mysterious disease has had on humans and
animals alike he'd be crazy not to be
nervous in one particularly terrified of
these families it barely makes it back
into the light there are vampire like
qualities mixed with their almost but
not quite human appearance results in a
haunting uncanny valley effects that
really makes the viewer squirm
never ate long time since seen that
movie yeah likewise
bugs will probably scare humanity until
the end of time let's just hope that
oversized extra-dimensional ones are not
what brings it about while so much of
the initial fear and that Stephen King
horror comes from the potential for
accidents earthquakes and other such
worldly concerns the people waiting out
the storm soon encounter forces far more
disturbing between the creatures killer
CG of nightmares come to life
the off-putting and so Lovecraftian
right now tentacles and XS are azog the
Defiler The Hobbit franchise towering
above our heroes this wicked looking orc
chieftain is called okay horrors also
really textured the title isn't horror
chasing after thorn and his companions
astride his gigantic white warg he makes
for a truly nightmarish figure just look
at that horrible grinny presents when
faced with danger ministry have been the
medical coding the mocap performance his
rugged good looks made it into the final
creature design with his short temper
rudl strengthen upgraded blade arm azog
is one orc that will keep you up at
night
I mean I was more distracted that
dreamcatcher he wasn't practical effects
when I was watching dream catchers
getting a shout-out Damian Lewis yeah
Wow
from the work of Stephen King our heroes
first encounter a slimy oversized
parasite when its huge fangs this
nightmare slug is already plenty freaky
but it is nothing compared to mr. Gregg
himself a tall humanoid alien mr. gray
is seriously imposing but it's his party
trick that really terrifies what there
we go
when he later exits the body he's
possessed we're presented with another
form a giant sawtooth beast with a
razor-sharp tail forget a dreamcatcher
after meeting mr. gray you will never be
able to fall asleep again Thomas Jane
movies Dementors this is pretty creepy
really says it all when it comes to
these ghastly creatures floating around
like foreboding embodiment of death
these rates feel like hell on earth
guarding Azkaban mothers they feed upon
happiness making time in the Wizarding
prison and even worse fate than one can
imagine devouring human souls these
large goals are just as scary to think
about as they are to see face to face as
they chill the existence of loss of
seeing this around them given their
seemingly endless numbers and with no
way to destroy them the only thing
scarier than a Dementor is a Dementor
working with Voldemort
[Music]
number four right buddy
in those McCobb tale of magic and demons
mecha brief scene is cursed proper
denies a gypsy and extension on her loan
no hell is well-trod ground conceptually
the first hand look at the underworld
provided in this film will leave you
hiding behind a blanket at the beginning
we get our Caroline first look and don't
make anyone want to turn over no no that
last book is the best help for their
cursed son final moment wait Anna Bruni
NetherRealm opens below him his hands
drag him screaming into its fiery death
number three aliens signs dude there's
like seeing the confirmation of you that
scene was some people say they laugh and
they saw I was like that's scary
my family is terrorized in their own
home when they start seeing crop circles
in their cornfield among other on an
unsettling occurrences when it finally
gets its moment in the spotlight the
giant extraterrestrial proves to be both
fast and strong he has made all the more
sort of alien that'll make you think you
smell a narrow little Breslin that's
right yeah dude I mean what's the brain
sucker one that one's gonna grab the
expansive bug race that terrorizes
colonies and military forces in this
site by satire comes in so many shapes
and sizes
it's hard to say which one looks exactly
like the one from totally John and Claud
warrior bugs that can rip people in half
to the swarms of equally dangerous
flying bugs there isn't a welcoming
creature of known book alongside most
bugs and building-sized tankers that
spit acid in artillery each subspecies
is terrifying in its own way even the
slow breeze there it is I have seen that
in person oh you have oh my oh that's
right
oh god I'm sensing a theme up now and
multiple team mouths and number one the
giant monster Cloverfield really ever
seen the whole scope of a monster makes
it somehow even more terrifying given
that we only catch the most sparing of
looks at this massive beast at any given
moment it lands in that perfect middle
ground to inspire the viewers minds to
fill in the blanks with even more
ungodly terror mixing amphibians
stretches of skin among other features
along with jagged arms and beady eyes
the parts we do see if this colossal
Titan are grizzly with its massive jaw
equally visually DS this monster proved
itself as scary on screen as it was off
so I try to get someone to CGI me into
the Cloverfield movie so I could like
ducked and dodged the Statue of
Liberty's head but we don't have that
budget so whatever to console me can you
guys hit that like button and be sure to
check out these related videos where
we're talking about us that was good
enough in every video what we wish we
could have done with that there you go
you know I thought was scary
who's that mama mama was scary and very
CG enhanced that is true I became like a
meme like a scary ask me where it's just
like floating and it's into like a
background and it's just yeah that's
good to crap yeah when things move
unnaturally fast and roar in ways they
shouldn't yeah very unnerving to say the
least
I like the way this list was done
because they kept it where it was all
CGI I would say watching the footage of
whatever that creature is from The
Hobbit here I think is effective and
scary I was never scared when I watched
the movie I was so aware of a CGI and so
much of that is lent to the fact that of
whatever one has always said about like
Lord of the Rings it a lot more
practical and Hobbit one full blown CGI
so watching that character although I
just my mind would constantly go why
didn't the practic
yeah so I can't really say it's one of
the scariest but I also can't argue
putting it on the list yeah I don't care
enough for or disagree enough to argue
it off but I saw that movie in 48 frames
which I actually didn't hate but all the
azog scenes or most of them were a
heavily CG for most every element on
screen and those really and I don't mean
this hyperbolically they started to look
like video game cutscenes yeah so I was
often distracted by him because of that
yeah oh you know who else I I think
would be great
um be oh why am i blinking the Aquaman
the Trent Reznor's the trench movie
about them I thought they were really
skewed like terrifying CGI monsters or
what about the ones from attack the
block simple design marriage of
practical and CG effects
what about Alien Resurrection when
they're in the water and the Xenomorphs
or swimming or an alien covenant when
they're in the ship and the Xenomorphs
are on top of the ship yeah the cabin in
the woods one it's funny because there
are a crap ton of monsters in that
finale but that is the iconic one it's
so unsettling because you know something
messed up is coming but there's
something just so off-putting about when
you really distort the human form to the
point where you're like all real and
then teeth and you pointed that out and
slay yeah gaping meld with lots of teeth
are like a very well tread horror trope
well I think it works because of the
fact that these are body parts that we
have they're just placed in weird
quantities and in different sections you
wouldn't expect it's a really yeah I
think it does something to the brain of
some kind of abnormality deformity that
could be potentially linked to a
humanoid organism of source those are
the biggest words I've ever used very
much alright as I'm thinking about the
list I'm also simultaneously trying to
think of other CGI characters the signs
one I'm glad they put it on the list I
don't really find that the
design scary because a lot of times the
CGI effects they they work best through
obscured vision like what they were
talking about with Cloverfield for an
example like that's true it works
because of the obscured vision I think
there's only one moment if I'm
remembering the movie one moment where
you get a clear shot where the cameras
pointed up and it looks down and it says
am I ready for my close-up I'm ready for
my close-up mr. Matt Reeves that's right
he only produced that yeah that's right
oh wow how are you survived modown 44
the same goes for the mist and that's a
movie to where the effects actually kind
of play better in black and white
because I think so timing is reduced you
have the version of black and white
right yeah I appreciate that movie
because the point isn't the monsters so
they're still able to be scary because
of the context and stuff like that but
there are a number of movies on this
list actually that I feel like I've
heard people debate the effects of
that's one that came to mind but I'm
glad it made it here the thing with the
miss is I think if you don't pick up on
the b-movie schlock enos of the effects
I've never heard of the filmmakers speak
on it but when I saw the movie that's
how I took it was it's kind of like
throwback vibe effects then I could be
wrong and it they just didn't have a
budget like an white version makes me
think that you know what's the scariest
effects today deep fakes deep fake
technology is impressive hilarious and
terrifying yes you never know what
they're gonna do now with these
celebrity faces they go how scary it is
how they can mislead the world what if
it gets to the point where politicians
are being deep faked what if Trump has
never given any of these speeches oh my
he's not even doing any of this I didn't
even finish up my thought on that you
see with signs I'm not a big fan of the
final scene for a variety of reasons but
final scene in terms of just its effects
because it's too clear of a shot whereas
that moment at the party where you do
get a clear-cut shot of the alien but
it's still fairly obscure because of the
kind of camera quality that is capturing
it
that it's way in the background now they
have to zoom into it distill some of the
pixel quality so you do get a different
as opposed to like cloud and shades and
darkness you get a different type of
obscured aesthetic when it comes to that
alien I thought that moment in it of
itself was very effective funny enough
though I mean you brought up the the
brain sucker and I'm sure they used CGI
and practical in Starship Troopers but I
have been in the room with that big
giant creature that may be there and
it's really unsettling because it's all
it is huge I forget which effects house
did it but in their warehouse they have
it it was terrifying and yeah that's the
main thing I ever said I don't know I
barely remember the other the main
creatures they're shooting in the movie
I might always flashes to the brain
sucker I mean the best kind of scary
monsters often if you're gonna do like
big monsters something that's totally
out of this world where you only do CGI
obscured vision or really dark lighting
goes a long way things like the
Dementors are usually in some even when
they're playing Quidditch and that one
moment they showed it's still coming
through the clouds so there's some type
of way to mask certain parts of it or
you can see it in real dark lighting the
hollow man stuff is that unsettling but
I don't think it's aged well yeah it's
gross for sure yeah but in a few years
it'll look like a lawnmower man I'm
surprised there was no mention at all of
Jurassic Park that's what I was thinking
yeah yeah because that movie I mean is
obviously marriage of CGI impractical
but that a broke huge ground for CGI and
B still holds up and C is pretty freakin
scary well I think it's because what
they were doing was bringing to life an
animal that already existed mmm-hmm you
know what I mean
how already exists point but there's
also the side of we don't know a hundred
percent for sure
what the dinosaurs really look like we
have good scientific evidence to back it
up there's always people going actually
a raptor really would have looked like
this back then
here's what a t-rex really would have
looked like and their sound design on
the roars were a combination of
different animals that way I felt real
the roars that we associate with
dinosaurs primarily due to Jurassic Park
are not authentic to what the dinosaur
sounds like there's one way what are you
having them on there but I think a lot
of the t-rex - there's a lot of CGI but
also a lot of it is animatronic but then
again they didn't mention it here is an
honorable mention but they call it true
form yeah yeah that's what a little tiny
baby you're a clown you're a clown but
the one that surprised me the most
oddly was I am Legend because I remember
when that movie dropped everyone dogged
the CGI specifically oh really
yeah I feel like I feel like that movie
has kind of gotten a black eye over time
especially for yeah the CG not being
incredible so especially the finale yeah
being very obviously CG and I point out
even the uncanny valley which I feel
like really could go either way for
people because for some people yeah it
does make it more creepy and for others
I would imagine it just breaks the
effect more but yeah cuz I think they
were going for other than the movement
and like the crawling of walls I think
the design they wanted it to still look
human where maybe they might have
benefited from just going all out with a
complete deformity I don't know because
there are so many moments that are in
the dark that I feel like you could
imagine just those moments yeah almost
look great but the main guy though the
leader guy yeah he looks like the dude
from The Hills Have Eyes
Michael Berryman's guys leave your
favorite CGI's scary effect your
subjective one down below subscribe
watch it click a bell any bell some ring
your doorbell hey let's give a pitch for
the day shout out
Andrew Hayes sometimes when I arrive
pumps John axe them out John wrote you a
rat so what we're gonna do today is I
haven't read this not one I'm gonna do
it for you oh thanks man here we go
you're right I'm excited I'm excited now
all right ready all right one Anna -
what a day what a day I was gonna do it
oh sorry you're gonna do the breath yeah
oh and I'll act it out oh dude are you
act it out all right yeah you liked it
oh I'm so sorry I'm gonna do this in my
favorite kind of rap style 90s hip-hop
what a day what a day it's time to shout
out Andrew Hayes one of the greatest
damn patrons in the u.s. of hey if you
need your locks changed
he's the menu on a ring five foot three
Wolverine smelling sweet like pop
potpourri potpourri that's how you spell
potpourri yeah huh I never knew there's
a tea there mm-hmm huh curry this man
Andrew it's all he can do to keep the
film reviews coming why the rainy dark
sunny this man's got mojo like the bunny
Oh behave go to a rave let Andrews
ecstasy embed a few just by standing in
the same place sometimes got a beard on
his face but it can't hold back that
smug loose boys introduce a ride-or-die
so popular survivor God oh my I think
I'm smitten watch that mojo cuz I'm
hitting on you Andrew did it hurt when
you fell from heaven because Halle
yuh-oh halle-loo yeah lucky number
Slevin little ass rhyme there we're for
uh heaven so I was lucky number Slevin
Oh which I think Andrew likes that movie
so uh but don't call me you hate that
movie
I apologize well done though it's
exactly what I had